Bruits de tambour brésilien (djembé)
"SUB REDIT"
"Cela fait un petit moment qu'on s'est pas fait un petit sub redit. Souvenez-vous, on avait découvert ça avec les erreurs d'ingénieur."
"Encore aujourd'hui je reçois, peut-être pas tous les jours mais à peu près toutes les semaines, des images, de vous."
"Qui tombez sur un truc qui est un peu mal conçu et vous vous dîtes"
"Hé, je vais l'envoyer à Squeezie pas apport à sa vidéo de il y un an"
"Et c'est trop mignon (rire choupinou de votre vidéaste favori)"
"Y'a un sub redit qui a attiré mon attention, car il s'agit de l'inverse, le strict opposé d'un sub qu'on a fait y'a quelques mois"
"Et qui s'appelait: le YES YES YES NO, où c'était pleins de vidéos où ça commencait très bien mais y'avait un élément qui foirait complètement."
"Et ducoup, c'était stressant."
"Là c'est l'inverse. Cela commence très mal, mais ça se finit très bien."
"Et ducoup c'est très satisfaisant!"
"Aller, trêves de plaisanteries. C'est parti pour une vidéo qui s'appellera "ça commence mal mais ça finit bien."
(rires choupinous de votre vidéaste préféré)
"Tu sais vraiment le titre c'est magnifique!"
"Okay! Premier: Jenga player makes the ultimate move"
"Oh ça va..."
J'y crois pas."
"J'y crois pas mec..."
"Mais, whoua!"
"Même grand père est étonné de ce qu'il vient de se passer"